Speaker 1: . I would encourage you to join
the discussion on The David Pakman Show sub
Reddit.
We are just so close, so close to 30000 of
our viewers and listeners being subscribed
to the sub Reddit.
Find it at David Pakman dotcom slash Reddit.
Some interesting posts from this morning.
One article lets us know that creationism
can be taught as science in Arkansas classrooms
according to what lawmakers there are saying.
And indeed, it is horrifying.
House Bill 17 oh one has passed the House
in Arkansas, which will allow the teaching
of creationism as science for kindergarten
through 12th grade, kindergarten through 12th
grade, not in religious studies, mind you,
as science, it now goes to the Senate.
I don't know if it will pass the Senate, but
this is very, very ugly.
We talk about education on the program quite
a bit.
And I point out that while it would be great
to deal with some elements of the educational
problems federally in the United States, much
of education is decided at the state level
by state boards of educations, of state boards
of education.
And this is one such example.
It's absolutely horrible.
We will see what the Senate does state Senate
in Arkansas, but at least the state House
saying, yeah, creationism that belongs in
science class, which is a horrifying, horrifying
situation.
Another post on the sub it about the latest
police shooting says in the army there is
no such thing as an accidental discharge.
There are only negligent discharges, saying
the Army is very lenient when it comes to
mistakes made in the heat of the moment.
But if a soldier failed to do his or her duty
by ensuring they employed the correct weapon
and that negligence resulted in a death, the
soldier would be facing non-judicial punishment
as a bare minimum, but likely a court martial.
That soldier supervisor would also be held
accountable.
Why aren't cops held to the same standard?
Well, understand, as is pointed out in the
thread, that there are ways in which the military
actually has higher standards than domestic
US based police forces.
And this often relates to use of force.
But yeah, as I said earlier this week, I believe
from the video that the officer in Brooklyn
Center, Minnesota, did not intend to shoot
the victim.
But that doesn't make it an accident where
we say let's just walk away from this thing.
It was an accident.
It's negligence when as an officer, you know,
you as a police officer, you don't need to
know much about, for example, astrophysics.
But you you do need to know whether you've
got the Taser or the gun.
That seems like a fundamental fundamental
part of policing.
She has been charged now with second degree
manslaughter.
And we'll talk about that more on the bonus
show and see what that is likely going to
look like.
One other thing, a bread for all user bread
for all posted.
Does David Dipak Pakman, the first of The
David Pakman Show on YouTube and elsewhere,
actually have a middle name?
I do not.
And what distinguishes me from the other David
Pakman, the venture capitalist who we've had
on the show is he has a middle name, he has
a middle name, and I do not.
But no, I have no middle name.
And I want to be publicly, fully known that
that is the case.
OK.
Join the discussion.
Whether it's about police shootings or my
middle name, it's all valid on the sub Reddit,
which you can find at David Pakman dotcom
slash R.E.D.
Det.